what is at the very top of your
education reform I think there are three
big things at the top of the reform
agenda number one professionalized
teaching teaching right now is basically
a assembly line right and we have got to
reward excellence have consequences for
non-performance but really make teachers
the heroes and not lock them into an
assembly line mode number two is to give
all families choice you know middle
class families we all want choice but
some reason we think poor people should
only have one school the neighborhood
school and if that doesn't work tough so
I want to open up choices more charter
schools more public school options and
number three to use technology and
software in a very different way to help
instruct our children we have a 19th
century classroom model in the 21st
century so those are the three big
things and your next gig is going to be
pushing new new methods of learning
exactly using technology software
distance learning platforms
individuation so that we focus on each
child rather than think one teacher can
figure out the sweet spot in a class of
2016 what are what are the big outcomes
that would come from this I think the
big outcomes are really to dramatically
increase the number of people graduating
from high school ready for college right
now throughout the country and in New
York we have far too few kids graduating
period and even those that are
graduating we're not college or career
ready so we've got to change that that's
a future are they not graduating because
they can't hack the work they're
disinterested they're bored or I mean
isn't that if we make school more
interesting they'll stick around while i
think i think so i think if we if we do
a better job in educating our kids i
think we'll get better outcomes I've
seen that in New York our graduation
rate has gone up over the last eight
years 20 points at some 15,000 children
in fact I was just earlier today at an
event called grad nation in which they
highlight those changes but it's a
combination of engaging children of
instructing them well of keeping them on
course right now far too many kids fall
off track and don't get back on track
what are the big obstacles to the types
of change
this obstacle is the status quo has
enormous defenders I mean everybody
understands IRA but it's not just it's
not just teachers unions and well so
politicians a lot of times the
bureaucrats people who do well under the
existing status quo whether it's a
unions where this ippoliti shin whether
it's a bureaucrat vendors those are the
groups that will protect a status quo
that serves their needs even if it
doesn't serve the needs of the students
so to me the way I see this is we have
got to move to a customer-focused school
system when I say customer I mean our
students right now they're the ones who
essentially conscripted into a single
school except virtually every other
aspect of American society is shifted to
a customer-focused a worldview why is it
taking education so well that's a good
government tends to be different but
think about it our college system this
customer focused and still today
America's college system is respected
throughout the world our colleges and
universities our k-12 system is not
customer focused and as a result of that
we're paying a price and again the same
reasons is because there's a political
group that supports the status quo
because it works well for them whether
it's the unions the politicians who get
the benefits from the unions that's the
way this thing works